i thought i would talk about a thing
called a nightingale diagram
all right what's that
so it comes it comes down to the fact
that i was looking at
somewhat morbidly looking at covid
mortality data
and was kind of unimpressed with the
ways that i had available to plot it
and there's always this problem that
when you look at the usual way the data
gets plotted
that it gets like plotted january
through to december and then
it goes back to january again when
you're looking at multiple years and so
there's always this kind of
discontinuity in the data at the end of
the year which of course is not any in
any way
real it's not physical it's just the way
you choose to plot the data
so i was trying to see if there was any
way of plotting it in a way that kind of
gets rid of that discontinuity at the
beginning in the end of the year it
turns out this is a solved problem in
fact it's a long solve problem
um the reason why the solution is a
thing called a nightingale diagram is
because it goes back to florence
nightingale in the middle of the 19th
century
who as well as you know being famous for
her nursing was actually also famous for
her data visualization
we tend to kind of think of data
visualization as being a something that
was only invented
with the computer agent with modern
graphics but actually it turns out it
has a pretty long history
but she was one of the very early
proponents and in fact not only was she
producing beautiful plots but she was
doing them for much the reason where
that people do data visualization now
which was to try and make an argument to
convince
people of her point of view in this case
politicians
she ended up publishing a book and a
whole load of pamphlets which were
distributed
kind of making her case and it was
really the case for uh
good cleanliness standards when you're
treating sick people right
and that was really what kind of how she
saved many many lives
was by convincing everyone that actually
good cleanliness was the way to do it
the plot she came up with was instead of
plotting things as a line she plotted
things around a circle
and the her plots went through various
iterations you can kind of see as she
was in kind of improving the way she was
presenting the data so let me show you
the first one
that you came up with this was the thing
she referred to as a back wing diagram
and in essence you're going around in a
circle and as you go around the circle
for the different months of the year
how far out you put the point is to do
with the thing you're measuring and she
was also actually measuring mortality
this was death
in the crimean war this was death of
soldiers in the crimean war and so you
could actually see
when death's rates were very high and
then then she kind of jumps over to this
second diagram
to continue the circle around and really
this is showing when she started
introducing her her various
sanitary measures for looking after the
wounded soldiers
that the death rates plummeted and this
i mean this makes a rather salutary
point that the
what what's actually measured here
radially outwards is the deaths
uh per thousand soldiers per year
effectively
and it actually peaks at over a thousand
so what this is saying is that if the
death rate had continued at that rate
the entire
entire army would have been killed in
less than a year
um so she was really making a rather a
strong point
as i say it was kind of radially outward
she didn't like this version of the plot
um because because she shaded it in to
create this kind of batwing effect
she was concerned that people would be
looking at the area and thinking the
area was what was representing rather
than the radial displacement
and and of course they don't quite scale
the same way because because
area goes as distance squared and so
actually the the area
is measuring a different thing from what
the radius is measuring so in her next
sort of iteration on the
the plot that she's most famous for
for illustrating this she kind of came
up with a
colored version of the same plot only
now she has actually scaled it so that
the areas are representing death
and the extra subtlety she's introduced
is she's now got colors in here which
represent different things
so for example the blue were the
soldiers who were dying of disease
in the hospitals whereas the pink was
the soldiers who were dying of their
wounds
of actually the injuries they'd received
and this very graphically makes this
incredibly strong point that actually
the main thing that was killing the army
wasn't actually getting shot
it was what happened after they got shot
that they then got cholera and various
other nasty diseases and were dying in
the hospital
and again she shows the effect of what
happens when she uh introduces her
mitigation steps and suddenly that the
numbers drop
right back down again so all this
inspired me to think
that the right way of presenting the
mortality data when i was trying to
understand what was going on with covet
mortality was to do the same thing
so i actually made a a version of her
plot
and this is actually like like her first
plot this is actually one of these ones
where the radial distance is measuring
the mortality
and so i was really just interested to
see quite how out of line
this last year has been in terms of of
deaths
uh in the population and it's you know
it's pretty blatant when you look at
this that nothing much was happening
until you get to april then suddenly
things jump up to these incredibly high
values drop back down again to more or
less nothing very much but then actually
you can see from october onwards in the
uk
deaths have been riding high above the
average the black line here is the last
10 years
the pink is last year and then i
switched over to do it in red for 2021
and so in 2021 we're now hopefully at
least turning things back over again and
coming back down
but even for the last data that were
released in the uk for the middle of
february there's still
significant excess mortality over any of
the previous decade
professor tell me about how this deals
with the january december problem
so really there's nothing you know
because you're just going around in a
circle all i've done is i've just sort
of joined the lines up so there's
actually a there's a sort of
long-running spiral going around here
effectively
and so as you can see so 2020 here was
in this
tasteful shade of magenta and when you
get to the end of the year
it just joins on to the red for 2021.
there are all sorts of subtleties you
see in the data like there's this
dramatic
strange v-dip at the end of the year and
actually you can see there's a couple of
others at other points in the air
they're just basically when there were
holidays in the uk because this is when
dates
uh when deaths were being registered and
if the the registry offices are closed
then the
the registration of deaths just gets
delayed um so you can see all sorts of
quite subtle things in the data but the
the basic issue of the fact that the
years just join on seamlessly to each
other as you just go round and round
rather than getting to the end of a line
and having to go back to the beginning
again
it's a much sort of cleaner tidier way
of presenting the data
does it cause problems sort of writing
over yourself all the time though going
around in these laps
sort of all the overlap i mean in
principle you sort of lose you you lose
the data right in that it all lies
ends up lying underneath the previous
year but in this case you know i was
really just trying to show
that that most years don't vary that
much so the fact that data was all kind
of lying on top of each other
you can see in some years you know in
january february there's a worse flu
epidemic than another year
so that the number the numbers peak out
a little bit higher but really there
isn't a lot of variation from year to
year and actually having the data all
lying on top of each other in these sort
of
circles just underlines that point that
there isn't very much and that last year
really was very
exceptional professor if these
nightingale graphs were invented so long
ago
by florence nightingale and they're as
good as you say they are and clean and
i agree they they seem really clean and
clever why aren't they everywhere why
don't i open up the times newspaper in
the morning and see
nightingale graphs why do i see the
old-fashioned you know x and y
and i honestly don't know i i guess it's
partly because people are very used to
seeing
old-fashioned x and y graphs and so
actually you know you don't have to
explain anything to them
when you're showing them that kind of
graph and the sort of range of data you
can plot with these are
quite limited in the sense that actually
you need something which is sort of
cyclic which goes around like the months
of the year
so the other i think the original
purpose they were used for a little bit
before florence nightingale was using
them
was plotting wind direction and how
often the wind was coming from different
directions and again that's something
which you can kind of
show in that way because you've got
something which goes naturally around in
a circle in that case the compass rose
but it has to be something which is
naturally cyclic which this is professor
you're an astronomer
can we expect to start seeing these
nightingale
graphs in some mike mirrorfield
astronomy papers in the years ahead
i guess so if there's something in fact
yeah you could well do
in that for example we were looking at
the angles at which
uh galaxies are moving a little while
ago and actually if i thought about it
this would have been a really good way
to present the data
the other places you see this a little
bit are in kind of power diagrams
they're used for things like microphones
that show you that the direction in
which the microphone has sensitivity as
you go around
and you know as you point the microphone
in different directions but of course
radio astronomers do the same thing when
they're pointing their radio dishes
that actually they have you know the
where where
the radio dish when it's pointed in a
particular direction it's most sensitive
to things that are directly in front but
of course its
power doesn't drop off immediately as
you go in different directions
so i think it's used a little bit in
radio astronomy as well but really i've
never seen them used in astronomy
she called them coxcomb diagrams which
are i
and i had to look that up it's actually
the name for the hat that a jester wears
and i think it was sort of intended to
be a little bit self-deprecating that
this is just a fancy way of presenting
the data to get people's attention
just as the jester wears this fancy hat
to get people's attention
so she called them that they're also
sometimes called honeycomb diagrams for
reasons i don't quite understand and i
think that might originally be
meant to be something else professor as
i said you're an astronomer why are you
sitting around plotting
covert mortality rates in the uk um
just because i'm a scientist and i'm
nosy right that's the nature of science
you're just kind of interested
and you know i'd heard various people
make various statements about
rates of mortality and so on and i just
wanted to see for myself so i wanted to
go back straightly straight to the the
original source of the data
which in the uk is you know the office
for national statistics but they only
they'll provide you with excel
spreadsheets with the data in
and i wanted some way of then
visualizing that data um so that's why i
ended up doing it
you can catch plenty more from professor
merrifield on our sister channels
dedicated to physics and astronomy
they're called 60 symbols
and deep sky videos and if you want to
think more like a scientist yourself
why not check out today's episode
sponsor brilliant
among their numerous courses is this one
on scientific thinking
as always you can see it's superbly
designed and well look at that
really interactive not entirely sure
about that dog but
anyway i loved playing around in these
rooms of mirrors
and giving my brain bit of a workout at
the same time
if you already use brilliant why not
give someone a subscription
as a gift if you'd like to check it out
go to brilliant.org
slash numberphile using that url will
give you twenty percent of a premium
subscription
that's brilliant.org slash number five
an instability is something where if
something starts to grow it will
continue to grow
so if you start with a little
perturbation it just becomes a bigger
and bigger and bigger perturbation
and it turns out there is this thing
called the kelvin-helmholtz instability
which will kick in in this case so let
me draw the same thing again
but with just the beginnings of kind of
an instability in the middles